[موسيقى]
اما انتحر نتيجه وصوله الى نقطه ياس معهد
في يستمر بالواقع اللي موجود فيه حاليا او
الجن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم متابعينا الكرام اينما كنتم هذه
حلقه جديده من الذاكره السياسيه اقدمها
اليكم ونحن نستضيف في السلسله هذه الحلقات
مصطفى خليفه الروائيه السوري المعتقل
السياسي السوري السابق اهلا بكم معنا
استاذ مصطفى نتابع في هذه الحلقات
يجب ان لا اجن كان هذا قراري منذ البدايه
رغم ذلك كنت احس احيانا انني على حافه
الجنون عندها كنت اغني لكن بصمت اجلس افكر
وافكر فكرت مره هل يمكن الانسان ما ان
يوقف التفكير استعرض الماضي واحلم
بالمستقبل تحول الامر الى عاده احلام
اليقظه اصبحت مدمنه احلام يقظه ابني الحلم
شيئا فشيئا اضع التفاصيل الصغيره والدقيقه
مقتطف اخر من روايتكم القوقعه
في وسط كل ذلك هل كنتم تعرفون شيئا مما
يجري في الخارج
كان في انقطاع تام طبعا يختلف الموضوع من
سجن لسجن في بعض السجون
لنقل مراكز الاعتقال الاولى
من الممكن
بعد ما اقوم مضيفه من الزمن يعني
يعني دائما في ناس جدد
هدول الناس الجدد بيحملوا لك اخبار خارج
ايوه لكن
بسجن تدمر انقطاع تام عن الخارج نهائيا
ولا فتح هؤلاء الجدد بيكونوا بالسجون
معتقللات اخرى حتى ينقطعين عن الخارج
بيكون بالنسبه لكم الاخبار جديده حتى لو
مضى عليها سنتين او ثلاثه
عن الخارج نهائيا لا جريده لا كتاب لا
راديو لا حتى قلم او ورقه ممنوع كل هذا
المواظيفه انقطاع تام نهائي عن الخارجي
وصل بكم يوم في احد الايام من مواسم
الرياح المغبره التي هبت في سجن تدمر
الصحراوي عندما علقت جريده
صفحه من جريده عند الشراقه المفتوحه وكنتم
تتمنون الا تذهب بها الرياح بعيدا
المهجع بالكامل كل الناس اللي موجودين
بالمهجه
انظار معلقه بالجريده طبعا في البدايه كان
دعاء وابتهال انه علل وعسى تنزل لحالها
يعني على المهجر خوفا من اي حركه يعني
يقوم فيها سجناء وانه الحارس ما يحس فيها
وانه الحارس ما يحس فيها نهائيا يعني لكن
رؤيه ما يحصل في معرفه ما يحصل في الخارج
او رؤيه لانه معظمهم كانوا متعلمين
كلها الشغلات يعني الحرف المطبوع بحجزه
وانا هيك حكيت يعني الحرف المطبوع بحد ذات
بحد ذاته صار له سحر خاص انه انت مانك
شايف حرف مطبوع صار لك مثلا سنتين ثلاثه
خمسه عشره مانك شايف حرف مطبوع نهائيا
يعني هون الناس اللي موجودين كلهم هن
عباره عن الناس متعلمين ومثقفين وقوادر
واطباء ومهندسين يعني علاقتهم مع الكتاب
والحرف علاقه
وحميميه يعني حتى اشكالكم ما كنتم تقدروا
تشوفوها
في نهائيا ابدا ما في مرايا ما في مرايا
يعني الا بعد ما يعني بحالات معينه قديش
ضل الانقطاع عن انه واحد يشوف شكله حتى في
المراه
هلا انا بالنسبه الي يمكن اربع سنوات وفي
حالات اخرى اكثر من ذلك حالات اخرى اكثر
من هيك بكثير يعني
اكرم الله السامعين وحضرتك كيف كان يحصل
ذلك
بمهاجع السجون الدائمه غير الاعت- يعني
مراكز الاعتقال الاولى ايوه في كل مهجاء
في
تواليت
والسجناء نفسهم يعني يقتطعوا جزء من حيز
التواليت بيحاولوا الى حمام مشان ناس
يتحمم طبعا حمام بدائي الحنفيه ونعبي شي
وعاء ما نعبيه مي ونمسك شيء طاسه او شيء
وتواليت طبعا كان في معاناه انه مثلا انت
تكون مثلا 60 شخص بمهجع واحد بفيقوا الصبح
كلياتهم تواليت واحد فعاده بالدور بيسجلوا
دور يعني
في فتره الامراض التي انتشرت بس بموضوع
الاكل فهمت انه من الروايه على الاقل انه
كان في فترات شده وفترات رخاء فترات
الرخاء صارت عقوبه
بعد ما يعني ظلت سنوات هي سنوات حتى تماما
بحيث مثلا يعني انه حصه الواحد على الفطور
ربع رغيف مع ست حبات زيتون المفروض
البيضة تقسم على اربعه بالخيط
كل اربع اشخاص بيطلع لهم بيضه واحده يعني
ايوه يعني
[موسيقى]
كانوا احيانا يرغموا السجانين بعض
المسؤولين او المعتقلين ان يضعوا اياديهم
في الشوربه المغليه
هاي حاسه تتكرر طبعا تكررت كثير يعني
ونفس المهاجع اللي كان بعض
السجانه السعديين يعني بيتبول
بيتبول بالاكل نفسه بالاكل نفسه ايوه عدا
عنه بالاساس الاكل النفسي يعني نوعيته
كتير سيئه يعني مراه بطاطا مع شويه ميه
بندوره البطاطا على حالها هي وتراب تبعه
او الطين تبعها
اثنين سنتي او ثلاثه سنتي تراب
الرخاء نوع من العقوبه كيف
هذا صار
[موسيقى]
فوتوا بعيسى يعني سنوات الجوع
وسنه الشبع سنه استمرت هاي الحاله بمعنى
انه حاجه المهجع لنفرض متر رغيف بجيبوا
لهم 400 رغيف يعني في هدف معين هدف ممنوع
احتاروا الكميات الزائده من الطعام من
الخبز وين بدهم يروحوا فيها خلقت مشاكل
الى اول ما لاخر يعني كيف بدنا نتخلص
هو خبز السمون العسكري
انه بدك تتخلص من 300 رغيف كل يوم زياده
فبده
تمرسه بالمي
وممنوع تطلعوا طبعا ايوه تمسه بالمي تسوي
سائل وترميم بالمرحاض طبعا
الصعيد الديني طبعا يعني
القدسيه اللي
بيعملوها المتدينين تجاه الخبز انه نعمه
الله حرام
في البدايات خلقت مشاكل كذا بالاخير
الواقع كان اقوى من يعني
لانه يعطوا الفتوى بانه يجب محصورات صارت
الضرورات تبيح المحظورات فصار يوميا في
مهمه بحيث انه يتعين مثلا عشر اشخاص
بالمهجع مهمتهم هو مرسى الخبز وكبه البنت
قاتله كتير اهم السلم
المرض اللي يعني اثار حيله الاطباء كتير
هو مرض الجرب يعني
واستحاله داخل هذا
التهاب السحايا ايوه عاد عن امراض العاديه
اللي تجي قريب
انفلونزا القمل
من اول السجن الى اخر السجناء
لم يستطيع سجناء التخلص من القمل موجود
دائما فصار امر عادي يعني احيانا يستخدمون
ذلك ضدكم يعني
هنالك وكانها كانت يعني بسببكم انتم
دفع الريش العسكريين يعني كان يؤتي ثماره
احيانا في موضوع جلب الادويه في حاله
جرب جرب كيف حصل ذلك حصل ذلك انه يعني هلا
المهاجر يعني بتقول كاني نتيجه انه واقع
واحد ظرف واحد عم يتم ابتكار الحلول واحده
يعني دائما نعبر في تواصل بين رئيس المهجى
وبين رئيس النوبه مثلا تبع الحراسه
يعني هو يعقد صفقه معهم
وهذا طبعا لم يتم الا بعد ما كان
فتح باب الزيارات ايضا من خلال الرشاوي
اللي هو مدير السجن
فصار عند السجناء مصالح يقومون برشوه
يدفعوا لها يعني
في ناس ذهب كيلو ذهب مثلا
بيعطوه بس انا بعرف يعني
فقط
ما زاروا ما حكوا معه بس من بعيد خلوهم
يشوفوا ابنهم وهو ماشي اطمنوا انه هو حي
عشره الاف دولار فقط لرؤيته من الخارج
بينما زياره للدكسوفه مثلا بغرفه او على
الشبك كانت تكلف اكثر بهذه الفتره هاي وقت
صار عندي المساجين مصاري نتيجه زيارات
باموال
يعني في بعض الناس كانت تبيع
بعض املاكه مشان تامن مبلغ محرز تعرف انه
ممكن هاي زياره ما بصير في غيرها يعني
ما كانوا يحتجوهم او ياخذوهم الاموال لا
على مستوى صغير
مثلا
مشان جلب الادويه بيتم رشوه رئيس النوبه
او بسموه مساعد انضباط السجن سعد انضباط
نعود الى سياق المصطلحات البلديات
البلديات هلا بتدمر في سجنيا
متجاورين يعني الحيط على الحيط سجن لالنا
السياسيين بشتت
تنوع وانتماءاتهم يعني معتقلين رايي
معتقلي راي السجن الاخر هو سجن العسكر
العسكر اللي ارتكب جريمه اثناء خدمته
العسكريه اللي مثلا فرغ من الجيش او من
بعقوبات مختلفه يعني او ارتكب اي جريمه
اخرى مثلا سرقه قتل
جريمه اخلاقيه كذا داخل الجيش بيجيبوه
بيحاكموا وبيجيبوه بيحطوه
جزء من المساجين العسكر لمسونيين بسجن
الثاني بيجيبون للخدمه هدول ايضا بعد فتره
من الفترات هدول
نتيجه الجو العام بستشرزوا هذا التوحش
العام
[موسيقى]
ربما شهاده امام السجناء الراي نتيجه انه
هن مثلا الحلاقين الشعر اللي كمان كان
يصير في تعذيب في خلال الحلاق بالضرب على
السجانب شجعون نضربه
ايضا يمكن
طبعا كمان هون بنقول حسب تركيبته النفسيه
حسب تربيته حسب اخلاقه وحسب يعني الصلاه
كانت ممنوعه بالمطلق
واللي بيشوفوه عم بصلي يعني قد يكون
النهايه قد
المعتقلون يلجاون
هو قاعد
في سره يعني
المشنقه الى الاعدام يلصق لاصق على يعني
بالبدايه كان
صار بعض المسائل بمعنى انه السجين اللي
رايح عم صارت الحبل برقبته
مؤمن بيكبر بيكبروا صاروا المساجين الله
اكبر الله اكبر
رجعوا السجان مجموعه من الاجراءات منا
تكميم السجين بلاصق بلاستر بحطوه
نعم نتابع بعد الفاصل استاذ مصطفى شكرا
لوجودك معنا مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام
ومتابعينا اينما كنتم متابع بعد هذا الفصل
في الذاكره السياسيه مع مصطفى خليفه
المعتقل السياسي السوري السابق والروائي
الشهير ابقوا معنا
يضلوا بالسجن حتى يعني ممكن 10 سنين ممكن
10 سنين
كل من داخل هذا المهجى محكوم بالبراءه
يعملوهم احسن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم متابعينا الكرام اينما كنتم هذه
الذاكره السياسيه مع مصطفى خليفه المعتقل
السياسي السوري السابق والروائي السوري
الشهير اهلا بكم معنا استاذ مصطفى مره
جديده فمي مقفل احنوا الى الكلام اشتاق
الى ان اسمع صوتي انا احلم احد احلامي
الصغيره وقد صغرت كل احلامهم احلم ان اعيش
ولو ليوم واحد فقط في زنزانه انفراديه في
صمت مطبق لا ضجيج لا نظرات عداء لا نظرات
احتقار وانام خلاله نوما عميقا احلم ان
استحم ولو لمره واحده فقط في حمام السوق
احلم ان اقف على الرصيف احلم ان اسير في
شارع هادئ ظليل احلم بامي وهي توقظني
صباحا وانا ارفض دلالا ان استيقظ احلم
بشخص اي شخص يقول لي صباح الخير
طبعا
هذه الاحلام
احلام صغيره هي احلام كل سجين باغلبها
يعني ما عدا مساله التواصل مع الاخرين
لانه كان له وضع خاص ما كان حدا يحكي معه
ولا هو بحكي مع حدا وهذا الانسان بطبعه
كان اجتماعي هو بحاجه تماما للتواصل
الانساني مع الاخرين والتواصل الانساني مع
الاخرين يتم عبر الحوار عبر الكلام عبر هو
كان محروم من التواصل
حلم صار حلم بالنسبه اما باقي الاشياء
يعني ان تسير في شارع ظليل او ان
يستحم في حمام السوق كذا هاي كانت احلامي
كل سجين بطبيعه الحال
بموضوع المصطلحات ايضا او بموضوع الاتصال
كذلك الاتصال كان مصطلح بحد ذاته لانه كان
في طريقه للاتصال يعني
ضروره ام الاختراع كما يقال كيف كان يحصل
ذلك الاتصال بين المهاجع بين السجون
والمعتقلات
بالعاده يعني على اكثر من مستوى المستوى
الاول داخل السجن الواحد نفسه يعني هي
المهاجع متلاصقه يعني بين المهجر والمهجر
هناك حائط مشترك على الاغلب
كان يتم التواصل عبر النقر على الحيطه
يعني
كان من زمان يعني كانت ابجديه
صارت قديمه فكان في بعض الناس
يعني يعرفون ابجديه مورس
بجديد مرسل
فيها الارسال البرقيات يعني نعم نقرا شحطه
نقرا نقرا شحطه يعني فكان عبر الحائط
واللي كان بيعرف ابجديه مورس بيعلمها
لباقي السجناء كل طريقه لها معنى كل نقره
كل يعني كل حرف له اشارات معينه يعني
فكانوا عبر الحائط طبعا يتبادلوا
المعلومات البسيطه يعني مثل مثلا كم واحد
انتم بالمهجاع جاءكم حدا جديد بتعرفوا شو
عنا اخبار الخارج في شيء كذا لسه في
اشتباكات مثلا طبعا كحركه دينيه يعني كانت
فاتو كان في اشتباكات بين
الطليعه المقاتله والنظام والسلطه
في اشتباكات ولا بطلوا في شيء يعني اكثر
شيء بنسال عنه يعني في شيء
اشاعات بره بانه بده يصير في عفو مثلا
هاي المسائل تبادلها عبر الحائط طبعا
بالمهاجئ اللي متوفر فيها شخص يجيد
ابجديه مورس وشرط يكون المهجع الملاصق له
ينوجد ايضا شخص اخر يجيد اب جديد
في كان في داخل
المهجع عندكم ما يسمى بالحفظه حفظه يحفظون
بكل مرجع بكل ما جاء الحفظ في البدايه
بدات بتحفيز القران
في هناك رجال دين
يحفظون القران او يحفظون معظم القران
تعاونوا تتكاتفوا بحيث انه استحضروا
القران شفهيا
من
الغلاف للغلاف
تولوا طبعا من ضمن
خلينا نقول فعل الخير بالنسبه لهم يعني
تحفيز القران للشباب وللي لا يحفظ القران
وهذا كان يعني خليني اقول سنه قوي جدا
للمتدينين يعني اطراف الحركه الدينيه ان
يتلو القران عزاء عزاء للنفس
يقويهم من الداخل فكان هذه الحفظه هنا
كانوا يحفظوا القران وحضرتك كنت تحفظ ايضا
او يعني المعيه يعني
مع صديقي ما سالته عن ناحيه ما بعرف يعني
هو المسيحي بس اذا كان هذا بس حفظ يعني
بموضوع الدين الاسلامي واحكام الدين
الاسلامي والشريعه الاسلاميه وحتى
يعني سنوات طويله جدا
وحواليه يعني تتكرر المواضيع بس بالنسبه
للحفظ ليس فقط القران ايضا تطور الامر
صاروا يحفظه
معلومات
في البدايه حفظه اسماء
اللي ذهبوا للاعدام
اللي بده يروح على الاعدام في دفع مثلا من
المهجر
بيحفظوهم معلومات وعنوان
اللي بقيانين احياء يعني بدهم يضلوا احياء
وبيكرروا وبيكرروا وبيحفظوا يعني انه فلان
الفلاني من مدينه كذا
بيت وكذا عنوانه كذا بالمستقبل فيما لو
حدثوا انه طلع احد الحفظه الى
خارج سنه سجن تم اخلاء سبيله او الافراج
عنه هو المفروض يروح يبلغ اهالي الناس
هدول انه مصير ابنائكم كان كذا كذا تم
اعدامه بتاريخ بتاريخ كذا بعدين
حكينا عنها قبل شوي يعني
بيكون هو
تفتح له مجال الكلام يعني غير ممكن
وكلهم عاده بكونوا اعدام يعني
ممكن عشر سنين وممكن 12 سنه حتى لو حكم
براءه حتى كان كبير
كل من داخل هذا المهجى محكوم بالبراءه
نفس الشيء
بعد
تجي الاوائل
ممكن تروحوا اسابيع ممكن تروح
من سيعدم خبر كيف يحضر
ايات قرانيه يشلح ثيابه اذا كان في عنده
ثياب يعني الى حد ما نجهز يعني صالحه
للاستعمال لسه صالحه للاستخدام صالحه
للاستخدام مشلحه بيعطيها للناس اللي
بقيانين يستفيدوا منها وبيلبس اللباس
يعني
ممكن يصلي له ركعتين قبل ما يطلع يعني
ما كنت تشوف حالات يضعفوا فيها كتير ناس
العكس يعني كان في انه خلصت
الموت حق
وانا اليه وانا اليه راجعون انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون
وخلصنا هذا الجحيم وخلصنا هذا العذاب
وبودع الناس ببوسهم احيانا وبيروح يعني
انا لم اشاهد اي
ضعف يعني
سالت كثير ناس يعني قد يجوز نحن مو من
الناس اللي شفنا كثير حالات يعني لكن
الناس اللي عايشوا الموضوع لفتره سنوات
طويله يعني سالت انا يعني مثلا كان عندي
صديق اصدر روايه يمكن كمان مهمه عن السجن
اسمها ناجن من المقصده كمان
اسمه محمد برو نعم
انه في كان حالات ضعف
لم يذكر لي احد انه صار في حاله ضعف او
انهيار
استاذ مصطفى حتى عمليات جراحيه كنتم تجرون
في داخل الوجع كان في نسبه كبيره من
الاطباء
كان عادي يعني كانت متوفره
بالساحه بالصدفه مثلا
بيجيبوه على المهجر بيضلوا يحكوا فيه
يحكوا فيه يحكوا فيه
يطول العمليه لمده شهر طبعا اكثر شيء
متوفر بالسجن هو الوقت
والزمان
يكون مثلا حولوا الى اداه حاده ايوه قد
تستخدم بالهداء بالتهريب او بالغلط
غطاء الساعه الخارجي اللي من تحت كمان
بيبردوه بيبردوه بيبردوه بيحولوه مثل كانه
بصير مشرط يعني ايوه
بالمناسبه اللي ساقول له عمليه جراحيه
بالزائده طلع من السجن وراح على الامارات
توفى بالامارات ونعود معك الان الى لعبه
المصطلحات كما سميناها استاذ مصطفى نصل
الى تدفئه المعتقل تدفئه السجين معتقل
بمعنى السجين وليس تدفئه المعتقل كمعتقل
الجزئيه يعني بسيطه وكذا يعني ومصطلح يكون
مثلا المفروض
شخص ما بمعنى هو صاحب هذا المصطلح بمعنى
ده فيه بمعنى عذبه عذبه قلتله طبعا يعني
اضربه اضربه بحيث انه جسمه يدفع هاي هي كل
القصه يعني هذه فترات البرد الصحراوي
القارس
بمعنى اشبيعه ضربا حتى
جسمه يسمح حارا بس حتى في ليالي احتفالات
في الخارج ليالي راس السنه الى ما هنالك
كان في بعض الاحيان بعض الجنود يعني ياتون
الى ساحات
المعتقل ليتسلو
لبعضنا
يعني دائما يمكن كل سنه يعني خاصه في فتره
راس السنه
الطاقم اللي بيكون مناوب داخل السجن
يحمل وزر مناوبته داخل السجن للسجناء
نفسهم عنده يعني هي كذا وكذا احتنعتونا
نحتفل مع اهالينا ومع عائلاتنا براز السنه
يعني فيصبوا جامعه غضبيه عن المساجين يعني
بتسلوا بحفلات تعذيب وتعرف راس السنه
بتكون من ابرد الايام يعني
وبهذه الملابس المهترئه واللي لا تقي من
البرد نهائيا يعني وهذا حدث العذاب قد
تستمر ساعات يعني
ايضا بحفله من الحفله من حفلات العذاب هاي
ممكن ان يكونوا الضحيه مثلا
عدد من السجناء يعني يقتلون يقتلون يموتون
يعني يموتون اما بردا او تعذيبا نختم معك
هذه الحلقه استاذ مصطفى خليفه ولكنه تابع
على بودكاست العربيه بقراءه مقتطفات من
رواياتكم القوقعه
بصوتكم شخصيا ونتابع في بدايه الحلقه
المقبله تلفزيونيه شكرا لوجودك معنا اذا
نكتفي بهذا القدر في هذه الحلقه مشاهدينا
الكرام ومتابعينا نرجو منكم ان تتابعونا
ايضا على بودكاست العربيه
ونتابع واياكم تلفزيونيا في بدايه الحلقه
المقبله مع مصطفى خليفه الروائي المعتقل
السياسي السوري السابقه يعني هي عمليه
اذلال
نتيجه الزني 15 سنه وبعد 15 سنه تجبرني
انا اكتب لك برقيه
اشكرك فيها
[موسيقى]